[Music]
coming up on world stories gift-wrapped
from Moscow with love
tourists giving Catalonia pass but first
to Ethiopia where the cartoon characters
tip off girls stand up for girls rights
tackling the problems many of them face
the heroines wield magical powers and
encourage girls to find their own way a
look of captivation on their faces this
school in Addis Ababa is showing pupils
the first episode of tebab girls
t-bob means wisdom in amharic in the
series three clever super heroines fight
for the Equality of girls and women one
out of five girls in Ethiopia made
before age 15 and most of them will
never go back to school that means they
are moved from their opportunity to
succeed in life
t-bob girls wants to change this it's
important to the program's creators that
children can identify with the show so
they organize screenings of the pile
episode at local schools to see if
pupils like it we're doing this like in
different parts of Ethiopia also so
there do have seen so many girls crying
because they know what she's been
through so that is something close to
their heart something they know so they
can connect with that after watching the
show the children write down what they
liked or didn't like and which
storylines they want to see continued hi
Charla I'm so lazy I thought it was
great because it was about girls issues
I've never seen anything like it before
miss red double wound to Bob girls is
the brainchild of Proctor Wittig abou
the train master she could no longer
ignore the plight of young women in
Ethiopia so I said how can I solve this
huge problem obviously I couldn't be
read kindergarten everywhere
so I start thinking how can I reach
millions of children in my country with
less cost
but with quality education
Brook to--it has already produced three
successful TV and radio series which
educate children across Ethiopia in a
fun way
she hopes tebab girls will become a
success and help challenge taboos we're
starting from hardcore subject Lake stop
early married but the thing is you know
that is why the power of animation is
very interesting because it is animation
that is fictional so people can pick a
distance and feel comfortable to talk
about it and that's what we want the
first step is talking about it but it's
not always easy sometimes I get
frustrated you know shouldn't take me
ten years to get to this point you know
I should reach more kids I should have
been by now you know an old East Africa
distributing the programs is difficult
and resources are scarce social
entrepreneurship is not yet common in
Ethiopia their policies stone support us
because
we're still looked at as a
businessperson so we've been tasked
taxed the same way what the mrs wilfer
gan we're frugal innovators we have been
small resource we have to do a lot but
the team behind Tibet girls is strong
and motivated and they won't give up in
the face of these obstacles they're
still negotiating with TV broadcasters
[Music]
the winter skies over Punjab in northern
India are once again turning dark as
farmers burn off the remains of their
crop
although bad for the air farmers say
they often have no other alternative
we have this report Punjab India a land
of burning fields these have become
yearly scenes as farmers set fire to
straw leftover from their summer rice
harvests to make room for their winter
crops the practice is a major
contributor to North India severe winter
air quality issues and last year
pollution levels in New Delhi rose to
nearly 30 times higher than World Health
Organization standards
Surinder pan jolla has been farming in
the district of Patiala for 15 years but
last year's pollution crisis led him to
rethink his farming practices every year
we used to burn the straw and it had a
negative impact on the environment now
the government has put a restriction
against this practice and some of us
have tried to find a solution for it we
want to protect the environment
Surinder solution is a chopping machine
which he and another farmer invested
around two-and-a-half thousand euros in
earlier this year it allows them to
remove straw easily and put it back in
their fields to help with their winter
crops about 35 kilometres away another
alternative to crop burning is in effect
straw from nearby farms is chopped up at
this local power plant so it can be used
as fuel to create electricity the plant
uses contractors to collect straw from
fields with machines called bailiffs but
there are limitations to how many farms
they can cover in such a short window of
time many of these farmers are already
in severe debt and until they get the
assistance they need they say there's no
choice but to set their fields alight
someone else should solve this problem
the government should lift the straw
themselves or pay us compensation to
clear the fields we are fed up with this
situation
farmers know the environmental
consequences of crop burning but as long
as it remains the cheapest way for them
to clear their fields it will be a long
time before more buy into alternative
solutions concerns about the economy in
Catalonia are growing in the wake of the
region's bid for independence tourism
has slumped and the ongoing political
stalemate is taking its toll
[Music]
Patrick Schmidt works as a tourist guide
just five people have signed up to his
tour of the famous Sagrada família not a
good sign considering the church lies at
the heart of Barcelona's tourist trail
yes more cancellations than usual we're
almost 25% down since October people are
afraid with no official figures
available yet it's too early to know
exactly how big an effect Spain's
political crisis is having on tourism
overall but anecdotal reports suggests
the problem is acute restaurant owner
Carlos Manresa has noticed a significant
drop in clientele since September we're
30 percent down compared to the year
before things the one like this but the
problem is the situation is ongoing
Nido pero se puede man tener que sólo el
problema hotel owners in Barcelona
appear reluctant to discuss the crisis
but the word on the street is that
bookings are down about 10 percent since
the referendum 80 kilometers away in
Tarragona
hotel owner chef Geum nee is more up
front he says
Spanish tourists are boycotting
Catalonia en este momento a moment we're
seeing a 10 to 15 percent reduction on
tourists from Spain the total portion of
tourism in Spain is 30 percent and
fondue supination treinta por ciento del
total but some warned that without
official numbers there's a risk of the
consequences being overblown and
anecdotal evidence being used to inspire
fear magnificus massage tourism is a
pillar opposed to spanish and catalan
economy people use information to
overstate the consequences the kind of
warning to the catalan government
while industry insiders await the exact
figures it seems hard to dispute that
Spain's political crisis is hurting
tourism that's especially worrying for
people like Patrick Schmidt whose
livelihoods depend on it one in five
Catalans work in the tourism industry
[Music]
and our last report takes us to Russia
this week saw the return of Moscow's
Saint Peter and Paul Cathedral to the
country's Lutheran Church under Stalin
Protestant Lutheran churches had been
closed along with many belonging to the
majority Russian Orthodox faith
an air of celebration at a normal Sunday
service the last one before this
Evangelical Lutheran congregation in
Moscow officially gets its church back
Lutheran's are a religious minority here
in Russia most in the community have
German roots their ancestors came to
Russia centuries ago on the invitation
of the czars who promised land and
religious freedom but later the Soviet
government persecuted Lutheran's and
seized church property including this
Cathedral the community led by
archbishop DTH power has been using it
again since the fall of the Soviet Union
but so far it has remained Russian
government property it's like someone
started living in your apartment and
it's not yours anymore that you turn up
at the whole time you have the feeling
that it isn't yours at any point it
could end up in government hands or
other hands but now it's ours it feels
like home again well that's in the
middle in the officially atheist Soviet
Union many churches were repurposed from
1937 this Cathedral was used as a movie
theater and a film studio by then all
Lutheran churches across the country had
been closed and many of their pastors
arrested and shot here at vidiians Kerr
Cemetery in Moscow long known as the
city's German cemetery the scars of that
persecution are still tangible many
gravestones here were neglected and
destroyed after the Second World War the
Lutheran community struggled with the
additional stigma of its German origins
often associated with the Nazi enemy a
chest the return of our church to some
extent restores historical justice
historical truth but only partially I
hope that this will just be the
beginning of a new stage in the
development of our country our community
colleges the number of churches that
were destroyed and can no longer be
returned that's a crime of course the
Cathedral is being returned to us now is
good news this church belongs to the
congregation it belongs to the people
that come here and look after it
now the congregation is getting a church
to call home and since it's in the
capital they hope this transfer will set
a precedent and that the Russian state
will return other churches as
well
[Music]
you
[Music]